Curtis did you get to pitch up yes yes I
ditched ok stud is I think five times so
far and how much time did you get 0 5 10
minutes you know it's kind of you know
that's who you gettin and whether or not
they ring the bell so to speak you know
well they literally ring about uh yeah I
think they there was a bill 11 pitch but
then you know it stopped I don't know
somebody said it's probably annoying but
I but yeah there's like two to five
minutes and then one minute 11 pitch I
got ten minutes so the guy didn't want
me to get up so so how did it go like
well went well I I'm actually I'm
pitching I've written 15 projects at
this point and I pitched five today and
at risk I'm pitching three times
obviously it's mine you know number one
but I'm also pitching to other projects
that are near and dear to my heart so
one is front it's to logo TV my cousin
came out and I'm the only one it you
know we'll deal with her now and so I
wrote a project called front on her life
and then the other one called hazmat
it's it's a crime thriller terrorist
thing from the mine went Iraq three or
four times came back and dealt with some
interesting things that happen when he
got back as an injured person and but he
filed a terrorist attack in Charleston
South Carolina you know nobody ever
really heard of it so so I wrote it yeah
so anyway they kept the dirty bomber
there by the way and someone was trying
to get revenge for Charleston keeping
the 30 bomber and their brig in the Navy
Yard okay yeah so they were trying to to
us f student universe South Florida
students came up and they were going to
engineering students they're going to
construct these robots to blow up some
things because they were family members
of this guy so anyway so I wrote that so
that's on pidgin as well Wow yeah but
most of your what you write about is all
juvenile justice um that's what I right
most about because you know that
my field I actually I've written all 13
episodes that I was required to write in
order to pitch it to executives yeah
sony and a few other places I've been
you